ils sont venus de corée du sud pour
rencontrer les surligneurs douze
journalistes de plusieurs télévision
coréennes ont découvert le légal
checking la vérification des
informations à partir du droit la
spécialité des surligneurs de
l'université versailles saint quentin
les personnes qui ne sont pas dans le
milieu journalistique ou qui ne sont pas
reporter sont très exposées aux fausses
nouvelles et aux fausses informations
je pense que c'est notre travail en tant
que journaliste de faire cela et de
filtrer les fausses informations pour
nos téléspectateurs
donc je pense que c'est très important
d'avoir des personnes qui vérifie les
informations et des personnes qui
vérifie la vérité juridique des
informations avant que les fausses
informations seraient pas en général je
pensais que le fath chez qui c'est
quelque chose qui est fait pour les
journalistes mais aujourd'hui j'ai
appris qu'à l'université avec les
juristes
on pouvait collaborer pour faire ce
travail à partir d'exemples concrets
vincent couronne explique la
méthodologie des surligneurs la parole
des politiques analysés par les juristes
une méthode qui intéresse les
journalistes coréens notamment à cause
de la destitution de l'ancien présidente
par johnny et suite à une affaire de
corruption et d'abus de pouvoir en mars
2010 sept royaumes pose beaucoup de
questions sur la légitimité qu'on a à
faire ça et notre processus de
de travail c'est à dire comment est ce
que nous sélectionnons les informations
comment est ce que nous les trions et
comment est-ce que nous assurons de la
véracité de l'objectivité de ce que nous
écrivons par ailleurs les surligneurs
ont lancé une campagne de financement
participatif pour récolter des fonds et
permettre de se développer